this is uni a two-year-old binturong  with a face like a cat a body like a  bear and a tail like a monkey  these reclusive creatures are unlike any  other binturongs are native to the  tropical rainforests of Southeast Asia  and spend most of their time high in the  treetops they are excellent climbers  their long prehensile tails act as  another limb as they move through the  trees even when asleep their tails are  anchored securely around a branch the  binturongs flexibility doesn't end there  their ankles can rotate 180 degrees to  maintain their grip even when climbing  down a tree had first perhaps the most  curious trait at the binturong is it  smelled  buttered popcorn while pleasing to a  human nose the binturong scent is a way  to mark its territory and to warn rival  to move along the binturong faces many  threats the worst being habitat  destruction over the past two decades  their population has fallen  precipitously this is the binturong  you